today i'm going to talk about my plans
and my what i would like to
achieve in the new year
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here it's new
year's day in vancouver it's raining
today i'm going to talk about my plans
and my
i guess the resolutions or what i would
like to
achieve in the new year remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
and come and join me at link
uh to learn languages where i do
so
um yeah it's quite common to make new
year's resolutions i can't say that i
that that's something i regularly do
because
i find that i'm
often
saying to myself i would like to do this
i would like to do that
and i act on some of them i don't act on
some of them i do some of them for a
while and then stop
some of the things that i want to have
happen are kind of outside my control
uh but
nevertheless let me talk a little bit
about what i would like to see in the
year 2021
so first of all in so far as learning
languages i'm going to continue with
persian and arabic
and at some point i will
sort of refresh and try to get back into
turkish i'm motivated to stay with
persian and arabic because i have that
sense that it's becoming easier and
easier for me to read the arabic script
and that's the major sort of obstacle
for me preventing me from you know
advancing more quickly in those
languages because if you can read easily
then you can
you know
expose yourself to more and more of the
language so
for the foreseeable future i'm going to
stay with persian and arabic maybe come
summertime i'll go into turkish for a
while
one of the motivations is that there's
many turkish
you know series on netflix and my wife
sometimes watches those
so that's one thing uh the next thing is
with regard to link which is a big part
of my life
um
you know i am impatient to see the new
beta what is now the beta version which
i am using on my iphone and ipad which
is to my mind just so much more
attractive and so much more convenient
than the existing uh thing but there are
still problems with it so until we can
you know finish upgrading and there are
some functions that we want to have that
aren't there yet now that is not within
my control
that is our technical team and there
seems to be that it seems that there is
always new obstacles or new problems
we have increased the resources that
we're putting at the project
so like i'm hopeful that we can get that
out to people
you know uh
in the spring i'm hoping
so that's something that's outside my
control but it's something that no no
not only for myself as a user but
because i want to be able to share this
with other people i'm very much hopeful
that we can get that out
as i say in the spring well that's
something i would like to see another
thing that i would like to see
is something that i've mentioned before
and that is sort of
contributing somehow towards the
development of more intermediate content
more of the sort of people just talking
in their language
uh
and and we would want to feature that at
link as sort of a step between the many
stories and then genuinely authentic
content you know videos on
youtube or netflix or you know
audiobooks and ebooks and stuff like
that it's it's that intermediate level
of material which it can be
so
you know
easily accessible has so much resonance
it's connecting with people speakers of
the language how do we do that i don't
know yet
uh it's something we're looking at
within link
obviously we have so many languages that
we can't be paying for people in all
these languages to produce an unlimited
amount of content we have to figure out
some way that we can do that that
benefits everyone
so i want to spend some time on on that
but still the first thing is to get the
new you know link 5.0 done that's not
something i'm involved with i'm not
technical
uh but it's something that i very much
want to see happen in the year 2021.
um
you know i don't think i'm going to
stray outside of
the the languages that i'm now learning
i may i did have a look just for the fun
of it in in the new link because i find
the sort of sentence mode with time
stamps such a convenient way of learning
difficult languages
i went and had a look at finnish and
indonesian languages where i have no
knowledge
and i found that it was quite easy to
get started say in a mini-story you
listen to the sentence
you look up each word
then you go to the next sentence you
look up each word and of course you hear
the sentence spoken by a native speaker
and just by doing that and looking up
words and some words show up again and
again because there's so much repetition
i have no doubt
that uh without even worrying about the
niceties of grammar in finnish or
indonesian that simply by putting the
time in to those languages
uh i could get the same toehold in those
languages as
i was able to do in persian and arabic
in fact easier because both those
languages are written in the latin
alphabet
so i just wanted to do that because
people often say to me well how do i
listen and read if i don't know anything
well of course you don't know anything
at the very beginning
but i think the the many stories the
sentence mode
all the functionality there makes it
quite easy
to access the language almost in
mid-stream because the mini stories are
not sort of total beginner content there
it's simplified there's a lot of
repetition a lot of very common verbs
but it's not necessarily
sort of
hello my name is kind of content so
i don't think i'll go back to finnish in
indonesian
i just did that as an experiment it may
be that
once we have link 5.0 up and we're
supposed to have thai and vietnamese and
georgian and a whole bunch of other
languages i might just experiment a
little bit just to have a look at what
those languages look like and of course
once you remember it linked you can
explore all the languages you want
very tempting
but insofar as my sort of commitment for
the year 2021 i i
do feel myself you know achieving a
greater and greater level of
comprehension in arabic and and persian
so i i'm not a i'm not going to allow
myself to be distracted and if i do move
away from those two it'll be into
turkish because that sort of helps to
complete
a sense of the middle east central asia
and of course i'm reading up on the
history of that region so i'm very much
committed to getting a better handle on
all of that
and
if i were to make an another sort of
geographic move it it might very well be
into the asian
into the yeah asian subcontinent south
asia india indian languages we have a
lot of punjabi speakers here in
vancouver maybe we'll do hindi i don't
know but that's a little bit beyond the
horizon at this point so those are my
sort of
thoughts
what i hope to achieve what i hope is
going to happen in 2021 and where i'm
going to put my
focus
uh thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]